President Trump is pushing for new
border wall funding India's four point
seven trillion dollar budget proposal
and includes seven hundred and fifty
billion dollars in defense spending
eight point six billion dollars for
barriers on the southern border and cuts
to domestic spending including nearly
two hundred and twenty billion dollars
to the program that provides food stamps
over the next decade the former
Republican senator from Arizona Jeff
Flake is a CBS News contributor welcome
senator we'll get to the budget in a
minute
we know president's budgets are dead on
arrival way to get to Congress but we'll
get to that in a minute I won't ask you
about something that happened over the
weekend a conversation between two vice
presidents remember Vice President
Cheney and the current vice president
Mike Pence it was about foreign policy
and national security was at the
American Enterprise Institute gathering
but this is where the Republican think
tank or it had been Vice President
Cheney was critical
across the board about the Trump
administration's foreign policy saying
it looked more like Barack Obama's
that's a bigger debate isn't it what did
you make of that back-and-forth I'm not
sure how much it looks like rock obama's
but it certainly doesn't look like a
republican foreign policy that we've
engaged in over the past couple of
decades republicans have long believed
in strong american leadership around the
globe so this kind of protectionism on
trade policy isolationism on security
policy basically going against your
allies that that just is foreign to most
Republicans so Mike Pence well in
Congress Republicans were far more like
Dick Cheney than the current trump
administration john bolton who is the
national security adviser was from
putting on the weekend so with this
tension it exists even within the
administration a little bit but what the
president would say is hey I was elected
to get us out of these foreign
entanglements he said George W Bush
should have been impeached for the Iraq
war
so doesn't he have a constituency to
which is why is America getting involved
in all these messy business all around
the world right it's not so much getting
involved in these businesses but
President Trump was also very critical
of Barack Obama for pulling out of
Arak prematurely and so some people
would say that's what we're doing or
that's what you proposed to do initially
in Syria
he's now gratefully I think slowed that
down a bit
so I think that certainly people don't
want to get involved in foreign
entanglements
but people value American leadership
around the globe and when you involved I
was chair of the Subcommittee on Africa
and we have a lot of involvement in
Africa certainly after PEPFAR President
Bush's program to alleviate human
suffering but it also helped us with
security arrangements that we need to
deal with al-shabaab and Boko Haram and
when you isolate yourself you you know
the long-term implications I think scare
a lot of Republicans certainly I'm
worried about where we are what's the
likelihood of who stay on foreign policy
we continue to see Venezuela descend
into chaos multiple days now of
blackouts in the country what is the
likelihood of Maduro stays in power that
will see US troops on the ground there
no I don't think we will I think that
brings up a specter that we don't want
to you know to bring back and it you
know awakens ghosts that people don't
want to awaken in terms of our
involvement in Central and South America
but I I am pleased that the u.s. under
the Trump administration has strongly
said you know you know the Maduro you're
right as has to go it has to be a new
dawn for Venezuela and so I hope that
that can happen obviously without any
military intervention I don't think that
that's in the offing you don't I don't
what do you think with Nancy Pelosi
saying yesterday that impeachment won't
happen did she provide cover to a number
of Democrats who are in Trump districts
yes she did and I think that was a
purpose she's been pretty consistent and
saying that she doesn't want it I think
this is a wise move on her part she made
it very clear that this isn't where we
ought to go unless the evidence
certainly takes us there and the reality
is the Republican Senate would never
vote for impeachment stuff to see how of
all the Democrats who have announced
that they're running and some who have
not announced that they're running yet
who do you think the Republicans are
most concerned about well the one that
hasn't announced yet
certainly looks like he will Joe Biden
was here yesterday right
yeah Joe Biden is I think that strikes
fear and a lot of Republicans he can
speak to those states that President
Trump won and the Rust Belt in
particular and he's seen as more of a
centrist he was a senator for 30-some
years he knows how to work with the
Senate with the Congress and and I think
that that's certainly one that worries
Republicans and you were when you were
here last time I missed you last time
but you made it clear you are not
thinking about running against Donald
Trump is there anybody in your party who
you've heard is secretly considering it
that you would like to share with us
today wife's reaction to you know all of
us think about it obviously but I really
don't think that there's going to be a
serious challenge John Kasich has talked
about it and he would be a strong
candidate I believe he has a strong
record as a governor back in Congress as
well but that he's not decided to do so
Larry Hogan has been talked about he has
a strong record across the aisle yes I
do I said that consistently I hope that
somebody does if only to remind
Republicans what it means to be
conservative and what it means to be
decent so I do hope that somebody runs
it won't be me even where the
president's are holing right now it's
like they're not going to happen it
doesn't look like it
Senator Jeff Flake thank you thank you